ο λογαροιεσμός το φας που το λογαριδομόστο διάφορες άλλες τουείται αρκαι λιπά μεσα οκοινωτικής δικτύωσης
διαπέ φεύχουν υπάρχουν διαθέσημα προσπόληση όλα αυτά τα στιχία όπου μπορεί να τα αγοράσει κάποιος
και να μπορει νακάνει τι τοχοποίηση του μαζικά γίνεται κάποια επεξεργασία από αυτού δηλαδή ποιος
είναι τώρα αρχηγό θα στυνομίας είναι ο γύριος θα θεμιστό θα αρναού της αραβάζουν μια
συνηθεσμένη επιστολή ότι παραδήμοσιχάρη θε έχουμε τον ίδαμε εμπροσφάτα που εξέχουμε εντοποίσει ότι η ασχολησε
νεπαιδική πορωνογραφία βάζουν το όνομα κάτω αρχιαρχηγός αστυνομίας θεμιστώ θα αρναού της βάζουν τις φραγίδες
βάζουν και μια φορα για να από τη γύρο πόλ και το στέλο παλιά ήταν
και έναν άλλων οι μέλοτης εντοποίσαμε και είνα ξεξέληξε επιχείρηση να σε συλλάβουν να ρε
κάνω λάθος δε μας βάλει στόσα χριμα ακριβώς είναι δηλαδή είναι οι μαζική γι αυτή
περιμερικοί του ανδηλαμβάζονται εμενα μόνον μουστηα όχι είναι μαζικά οπο στελοντ υτά και αυτά τα
μηνήματα λέγονται φίση δηλαδή όποιος συμπίσει και γιατους εκληματίες έσπτο και δέκα να τσυμπσουν να
σεμαστόβασ είναι γίναι αρκιοκι αρχίζει και γίνεται να θυμ αυτούν πως και στι συνέχεια είναι
εκεί που ποντάρουν οι εγκληματίες ούτε όστε να καταάποιον τρόπον να εγκλοβιστεί αυτός που εδώκατα
τα χρήματα και να τους ζητήσουν περισσότερα και περισσότερα και πειαρισότερα για να μην υπάρχουν
οι συνέπειες για αυτό πως έταν τα πιο πολλά κρηματα που πηράν κυρι ένα στασιάδι
στην κύπρο και τα οποία ακληθεί κάτι να διερευνείς ετέσεις υπάρχουν μεγάλα αθηματικά πο άι
ήταν θαράντα παδίνετα χιλιάτες θυμάμε κάποιες περιπτώσεις που χάσαν αρκετά μεγάλα χρηματικά πόσα τώρα έχουμε
πέρασίστη νέα τάσυντου κλματος είναι ι απάτες για κερεπτονομίσματα υπάρχουν οι διικά διαφημήσεις